>>> A CONCERN OF THE NEW KING
CLIMATE CHANGE WAS ONE OF THE
MANY GLOBAL CHALLENGES FRONT AND
CENTER AT THE UNITED NATIONS
TODAY.
ONE OF THOSE ON STAGE TO FOCUS
ON THE SOCIETAL CONCERNS WAS
AMERICAN POET AMANDA GORMAN.
YOU MAY RECALL THE POEM SHE READ
DURING PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
INAUGURATION WHERE SHE SPOKE OF,
QUOTE, A NATION THAT ISN'T
BROKEN BUT SIMPLY UNFINISHED.
IN THE FOLLOWING MONTHS SHE
BECAME THE FIRST POET TO PERFORM
FOR THE SUPER BOWL.
HER NEW POEM IS CALLED "AN ODE
WE OWE" AND HER WORDS TODAY
FOCUSED ON ISSUES AFFLICTING NOT
JUST A COUNTRY BUT A PLANET.
>> HOW CAN I ASK YOU TO DO GOOD
WHEN WE'VE BARELY WITH STOOD OUR
GREATEST THREATS YET.
THE DEPTHS OF DEATH, DESPAIR,
AND DISPARITY, ATROCITIES ACROSS
CITIES, TOWNS, AND COUNTRIES,
LIVES LOST, CLIMACTIC COSTS,
EXHAUSTED, ANGERED, WE ARE
ENDANGERED NOT BECAUSE OF OUR
NUMBERS BUT BECAUSE OF OUR
NUMBNESS.
>> AND I AM VERY PLEASED AMANDA
GORMAN JOINS ME NOW.
AMANDA, IT IS SO LOVELY TO SEE
YOU.
AND THANKS FOR ALL YOU'RE DOING.
TELL US ABOUT THE BACKGROUND OF
THE POEM AND WHAT INSPIRED YOU.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
IT'S GREAT TO BE HERE AGAIN.
AND TO TELL YOU A BIT ABOUT THE
POEM, I WAS REALLY EXCITED AT
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE POETRY
REPRESENTED AT THE UNITED
NATIONS AND WHAT'S MORE TO USE
IT TO SPEAK TO SOME OF THE MOST
PRESSING ISSUES OF OUR TIME,
WHETHER IT BE THE CLIMATE
CRISIS, POVERTY, GENDER AND
EQUITY, ALL OF THESE ISSUES ARE
CONNECTED IN MAKING SOLUTIONS
MEANS WE NEED UNITY AND
SOLIDARITY.
>> IS THERE A PARTICULAR PART OF
THE POEM THAT RESONATES WITH YOU
MOST, SOMETHING MAYBE YOU COULD
READ OR SHARE?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
FOR ME, ONE OF THE PARTS THAT
FELT RESONANT FOR ME WAS THE
ENDING BECAUSE I WANTED IT TO BE
A CALL TO ACTION.
SO HERE IS AN EXCERPT.
THIS MORN LET IT BE SWORN THAT
WE ARE ONE HUMAN KIN, GROUNDED,
NOT JUST BY THE GRIEVES WE BEAR,
BUT BY THE GOOD WE BEGIN TO
ANYONE OUT THERE.
I ONLY ASK THAT YOU CARE BEFORE
IT'S TOO LATE, THAT YOU LIVE
AWARE AND AWAKE.
THAT YOU LEAD WITH LOVE AND
HOURS OF HATE I CHALLENGE YOU TO
HEED THIS CALL.
I DARE YOU TO SHAPE OUR FATE
ABOVE ALL.
I DARE YOU TO DO GOOD.
SO THAT THE WORLD MIGHT BE
GREAT.
THANK YOU
>> I LOVE THAT.
WHAT WAS THE LINE, THE GRIEVES
NOT JUST GROUNDED BY THE GRIEFS
WE SHARE BUT BY THE GOOD WE --
>> BEGIN.
>> WHAT WAS IT?
>> ONE HUMAN KID GROUNDED NOT
JUST BY THE GRIEFS WE BEAR BUT
BY THE GOOD WE BEGIN.
>> I LOVE THAT.
I WILL THINK ABOUT THAT A LOT
TONIGHT.
>> THANK YOU.
WHAT DO YOU WANT PEOPLE WATCHING
AND LISTENING TO TAKE FROM THIS
POEM AND HOW DO YOU WRITE
POETRY?
I MEAN, HOW LONG DOES IT TAKE
YOU TO DO SOMETHING LIKE THIS?
DO YOU HAVE A CONCEPT FIRST OR
DOES IT JUST SORT OF, DO THE
WORDS COME AND THEN THEY FIT
TOGETHER?
>> ANDERSON, WE AIN'T GOT TIME
FOR MY POETIC PROCESS.
BUT TO GIVE YOU A SNAPSHOT,
REALLY, MY POEMS START WITH THE
HEART OF THE MATTER SO TO ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION, THE THINGS THAT I
WANT PEOPLE TO TAKE AWAY FROM MY
POETRY, THAT'S WHERE I BEGIN.
I BEGIN WITH THE WOUND.
I LIKE TO THINK OF IT.
I BEGIN WITH THE PLACE OF PAIN.
AND THEN I LIKE TO FEEL A
MOVEMENT TOWARD WHAT BRINGS US
TOGETHER.
WHERE IS HOPE IN THE DARKEST OF
HOURS.
THAT DICTATES WHAT I WRITE AND
HOW.
>> THAT NOTION, I BEGIN WITH THE
WOUND.
THAT IS FASCINATING.
YOU RECITED THIS POEM AT THE
UNITED NATIONS TO DRAW ATTENTION
TO SUSTAINABLE DEVELOPMENT
GOALS.
CAN YOU TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
WHAT THOSE ARE, WHAT THEY MEAN
TO YOU?
FOR PEOPLE WHO MAY NOT BE UP ON
THIS?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THE SUSTAINABLE DEVELOPMENT
GOALS ARE AROUND 17 GOALS THAT
HAVE BEEN HIGHLIGHTED BY THE
UNITED NATIONS AND THEY RANGE
FROM THINGS SUCH AS, YOU KNOW,
FACING, GENDER INEQUITY,
EDUCATION FOR CHILDREN, GOALS
AROUND POVERTY AND HUNGER.
AND WHAT MAKES THEM SO
SUPPORTIVE IS THESE ARE AIMS
THAT COLLECTIVELY ARE ORIENTED
FOR THE WORLD.
SO WE'RE NOT JUST TALKING ABOUT
TOWNS, CITIES, COUNTRIES HERE.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE GLOBE.
AND MORE OFTEN THAN NOT THESE
ARE GOALS THAT OUR GOVERNMENTS
CAN'T GET TO ON THEIR OWN.
THEY REALLY NEED THE ACTIVATION
AND ENGAGEMENT OF PEOPLE.
I THINK ESPECIALLY YOUNG PEOPLE.
SO IF YOU DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE
SDGs, PLEASE LOOK THEM UP
BECAUSE WE WOULD LOVE TO H